maybe today looking back i would say
well you've done some crazy
crazy things karen and you should have
slowed down but
um i've got to say
there was always a bit of me that
wanted to impact uh what is happening in
the world there is a thing in me that
basically is always going to chase
justice and i thought that like i was
young and i thought that i could change
the world through revealing the truth
right but at the end of the day
journalism is a business like any other
business
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet kevin
pix the general manager of the breit
initiative by bright data
karen a former award-winning bbc
journalist has for over a decade covered
the most prominent news stories of the
period and led innovative programs and
initiatives when she left the bbc after
14 years the foundation moved to
management positions in the field of
marketing in the world of technology and
served as a volunteer spokesperson for a
number of non-profit social
organizations with the aim of advancing
them towards their important goals
karen pakis welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me how are
you
i'm fantastic how are you
i'm doing i'm doing great i'm so excited
for these 20 minutes where you know so
many different questions come to mind
you have such a unique background today
is the general manager of the bright
initiative by bright data and previously
having a lot to do also with with
marketing and communications both with
bright data but then also with mdocs but
even going before that before entering
tech in that that world you were an
executive producer and editor within bbc
for almost 10 years and so
again i i can't wait to to understand
with you you know what was that
experience like with bbc and with these
different things that you were doing as
a journalist and then transitioning more
into tech and but bringing a lot of
those those really meaningful
understandings so so karen thank you so
much for being here
i love being here and thank you for
inviting me
um i was a journalist actually in total
for 14 years
i didn't intend to be a journalist it
was uh by fluke
really i was a
psychologist student and i was an
exchange program here in israel
and a journalist came to lecture us and
i think that i asked too many questions
so at the end of the session he
i'm a i'm not a very tall woman so he
said you the short one come and talk to
me these are before the pc days
um and i came to talk to him and he
offered me a job and the rest is you
know
um i was 19 at the time
and started working as a journalist yeah
um
and the rest is history when i joined
the bbc it was also by coincidence
i arrived there was a whole committee i
wasn't even prepared they had a chair
that was too high for me and basically
my legs kept on dangling down
and they asked plenty of questions and
on the same day they let me know that i
was accepted to the job
i worked all around the middle east
um um america europe um africa
loved it being a journalist is like
being where history is made and back in
the day when i was very young you know
this is very exciting
um so all the war zones all the critical
political crisis
everything
and i love doing it
and when i left being a journalist i was
puzzled and didn't know where i should
go
and you know journalism and media are
sometimes similar to marketing because
at the end of the day we all talk to
target audiences
so i decided to try my luck um
and the high-tech
space
um apparently it's very suitable for me
because you know this speed and the
uh
racing against datelines and everything
like that is very much me
um and storytelling it's at the heart of
everything really even when you're
talking technology and products
so
i love it
that's kind of it uh a very quick
summary of everything that i've done
i can only a very very quick summary
obviously uh having spent 14 years as a
journalist and then working for some
some amazing companies and today
with today's experience with the bright
initiative and the work that you're
doing with with data and looking and
working with organizations on
understanding how how collection is is
made into the best ability
take me back a little bit though to
journalism because i really wanted you
know to dissect the the skills you
gained as a journalist that allowed you
to then be
a good storyteller to be a good
communication artist and and marketer
but real marketing is just storytelling
it had sometimes they give it a bad rep
but really it's just the ability to tell
what's happening you started doing it in
war zones what was that about how does
that experience teach you for today
well
um
maybe today looking back i would say
well you've done some crazy
crazy things karen and you should have
slowed down but
um i've got to say
there was always a bit of me that
wanted to impact uh what is happening in
the world there is a thing in me that
basically is always going to chase
justice and i thought that like i was
young and i thought that i could change
the world through revealing the truth
right but at the end of the day
journalism is a business like any other
business and obviously rating matters
uh when i i think that the thing that
made
the bbc a very good fit to me
was the versatility of the news and also
you're sent everywhere so for instance
i'll give you an example
um you don't know where you're going to
sleep the next like even today you can
be called into the middle i remember
celebrating one of my birthdays you know
having a party with lots of my friends i
got a call because there was a flood in
mexico i got on the plane two hours
later
um i had to read up very very quickly
um
it wasn't even a flood i'm sorry it was
a hurricane i reached the place i have
to get things on air within a matter of
minutes
and and understand the story and get
interviews and put together and edit the
story very quickly and those days it was
much harder than it is today
um and in general you know when you do
war zones
you forget that your life is at risk
you really do
you're all about the story i remember
that i once had to have a new journalist
with me and it was in the day of the
lebanon war in 2007
and he had no idea what was happening
all around and you know and there are
rockets flying around and everything and
he was looking at me and saying
you know what exactly is happening i
said just focus on the story and i was
very calm and it was when we finished
the day he looked at me and he said i
think
you need to
how come you're so calm and i i said to
him i'm just focused on delivering the
story and i didn't see anything else and
you know this is south lebanon it's not
like
in the days of war it's not like you
know it's not even like being in tel
aviv when rockets are flying from gaza
this is full-on war
you just don't see it you don't feel it
and i think that because i was younger
then i think i even
more so focused on my task and my task
was to deliver a story on time and that
is compelling enough and that you know
um beats the competition
so that was it
right now you're looking at it
you know
if i'm looking at you know the
the parallelism you know and and not
definitely not to to learn from the
magnitude of of a war and and what's
happening there but
but you know you're looking at you're
describing a situation in which you're
arriving to a place of crisis as a
journalist right a lot of times
you really and you sort of have to come
up with a product that you're basically
sharing with audience right and you're
basically building the narrative of
what's happening and you have to very
concisely
distribute that story to the world and
so that they understand what's happening
they buy into it they form an opinion
and they get emotionally attached right
because again that's you know part of
storytelling and so if you're looking
then at the high tech world
how do you come up with stories and how
do you know which narrative is going to
stick and how to tell a story the best
way how does it what does it come down
to really for you
so michael you put it very
very eloquently correct because at the
end of the day it's about a connection
to your target audience it's about you
know
people say that product storytelling or
technology storytelling is all about
russian now i or a narrative is about
regional it's not it's about an
emotional connection and you need to
talk to the hearts before you talk to
the heads
even when you're doing business you're
talking to the heart first okay i always
say that people remember the experience
you give them more than they remember
the words you're telling them
so for instance when i do a session and
i just did one yesterday about
a data and and you know the importance
of web data collection public work data
collection to the competitive landscape
so i don't tell them the story in terms
of the product and what the product does
and how we deliver it i tell them the
story
through examples real life examples
of how our product comes into life and
how it impacts their lives okay that
target audience life
so if it's the end user or if it's the
a business because we're a b2b business
if it's a b2b business and so on and so
forth so at the end of the day it's all
about that and it's about
telling it in a sharp way
that
just basically penetrates uh their heart
and if he was saying it correctly
because
you don't have that much time to tell a
story really and in the news days you
know i remember when we were fighting
for two minute stories that was a long
time nowadays like 50 seconds is enough
to tell the story or 40 seconds it's
really the same when it comes to
storytelling in tech
you know the first time that a customer
talks to you same way it's about your
opening and it's about
targeting exactly what he's interested
what is his pain points or what is his
challenges and knowing it and and and
relating to it right away
incredible okay bright initiative
sharp turn
today you know and
you there was there were a lot of
different things in the way with with
them docs and broad data but today
general manager of breit initiative
we're talking about data this is very
different from journalism it's very
different from
this from storytelling how to how do you
how do you explain this transition and
what is bright initiative for context
okay so
i'll start with a simple background to
the bright initiative and then i'll
address your question
um and actually you'll find out that
it's not that different and anyone who
knows me will understand right away why
i was why i established the bright
initiative
so
the bright initiative was born at the
early days of the pandemic well actually
because of the early days of the
pandemic when the pandemic you know if
you remember march 2020
when we all were under lockdown no one
knew anything about this pandemic what
is covet so we had we had researchers
around the world approaching us with the
emergency
to access data they wanted as much data
as possible within 24 hours to the to
make it kind of
uh
visible to you my ceo himself and two
developers including and and myself as
well all of us um decided to take this
project right away and we
delivered the data with under 24 7 24
hours uh to the to it was to a suta
hospital was in collaboration
with
um aws israel
and i think other if i remember other
bodies as well it was back in march
so we saw the critical need of data and
how data actually and i'm not being you
know i'm putting it simple simply and it
sounds really
big but it is that
dota can save lives really
so at the end of the day
we
we saw that more and more researchers
are uh joining
and i kept on like my the list kept on
growing and all of a sudden i had 100
organizations needing our data and this
can be organizations that are fighting
human trafficking organizations that are
fighting sex trafficking and how they
do
when you say they need data well what do
you actually mean what does that mean
that that an organization needs data
so i'll give you an example of an
organization for instance hti labs hti
labs this is an organization that fights
sex trafficking
now why do they need us
they need access
to
lots and lots and lots advertisements
that appear apparently on craigslist uh
for
sex trafficking really promoting sex
trafficking in certain ways they know
the codes they know the lingo i happen i
i don't think i'm very familiar with
human trafficking or sex trafficking
it's better than i wouldn't be um but um
um they asked us
to
help with
accumulating all this data now this is
public web data i mean it's not behind
the sign up it's not behind the login
it's outwardly open for you to see
so
in that if you have to do it yourself
and collect it it means that you're
going to sit hours and hours maybe days
and days collecting it we automate it
so this is what they needed from us and
this is what we've done a so far and
we've been in partnership with them for
a year now
and obviously our technology was very
helpful to them
and there are many others like i can
give you
um more and more examples say
if you wish but even in israel lm the
um are now they have this project called
new story
um that they look into
a social media to
find potential a
teenagers that are suffering from abuse
now it's not in full scale yet or
anything like that but together with
them
we partnered to basically deliver that
public data and to help them identify
uh those cases
so
you know
here it is it's doing good and we
understand that partnership and data can
really make a difference and we're also
involved in so many environmental
uh organizations and even we support the
nds the uk and ds national data strategy
and help them with our expertise and
we provide sessions on top of sessions
around the world even in israel um
you know ort natanya just a few days ago
did a session with us so um
we love it because it's all about
education it's all about
um
really changing things and when the day
with data
is actually the engine today behind
supporting our economy and data skill
sets are needed more than more actually
there's gaps huge gaps now in data
so this is something that we are very
much focused on and if to your question
at the end of the day also as a
journalist i wanted to change the world
but for the good
i love it
the the word initiative
with with bright well what does that
mean that it's in the the the bright
initiative why why is the word there
it started off with really an idea of
how to do it and like anything else with
my company because i belong to bright
data but i also belong to the bright
initiative and bright initiative is
separ and bright data i do marketing
um
so
it started off we didn't know it will
will stick okay when i started it
um and like my ceo's and and this is
what's wonderful about him my cs is
always said start small see what's
happening if it works let's turn it to
our organization so we started with the
name initiative and we loved it and at
the end of the day it remained an
initiative
it's now
obviously we have now close to 400
organizations partnering with us and
it's growing every day like only today
we had five organizations showing us you
know and the leading and they're all
leading a university so it's wonderful
to see and it's wonderful to see that
there is a need that we are
addressing um
and obviously you know we just want to
we look into ways now to build more and
more organizations around it and we're
going to build an academy while we're
launching an academy in march
so that's it
yeah i think it's incredible and i just
love the story of how it this started
off you know the use case of a pandemic
but but then you realize that there is
actually greater need around the world
for for the way the data is being
collected and obviously and
unfortunately a lot of these
organizations that are dealing with a
lot of these issues like human
trafficking and sex trafficking and and
you know they often aren't the ones with
the most capital that can now onboard a
team of data scientists and people that
can go on and and get the highest
quality data right and i'm sure that
they that they do have their own means
but it's it's definitely not the same as
as a traditional tech company that is
going on and needing the data so i think
obviously that
you're doing amazing amazing work now if
you're looking now at where you're at
as a marketer and as a storyteller what
do you enjoy most
about what you do it's a trivial
question but but not really like if you
look really at the core of what you do
what do you really enjoy most
i'll be honest um i'm still a sucker for
storytelling so
for instance when i have a university
calling me about a research that just
blows my mind you know we're working now
for instance with north eastern
university on the research that looks
into disinformation or misinformation
between china russia and united states
and we're helping it i just want to hear
more okay so i'm still attracted to that
i can't say that maybe this is the
part that will never go away
um you know today
my ceo told me a story about a farmer
that is using us to understand how to
better anticipate
a a
how he grows his own products or on
so
in a a farmer in the us you know and
we're helping him and still you know
i would say i'm still mesmerized by that
uh this is still what energizes me i
love the contact with people i can't say
i'm still a people person after all um
you know when i was a journalist
in order to do my job i had to connect
with people you can't get stories
without having like decent connections
with people um and and when you're doing
it fast you have to connect fast right
you have to right away speak to them so
i'm i'm still there it's still me i love
tech because the speed of tech is
amazing but at the end of the day it's
all about storytelling for me
i love it i love it
really thank you for for coming and
thank you for the great work you're
doing and i love what you're doing with
the with the pride initiative it's so
cool and your own journey is just so
cool as well so thank you very very much
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you very much michael for having
me
of course thank you take care
[Music]